in germany the potential invasion of
ukraine leads the munich security
conference an annual event to prevent
another war in europe ukraine's
president is expected to address the
conference today following remarks from
vice president kamala harris and
secretary of state anthony blinken the
u.s has agreed to sell hundreds of tanks
to poland to bolster nato forces
christina ruffini is traveling with the
secretary of state in munich christina
good morning
president zielinski i'm told um
i'm sorry go right ahead
that's okay good morning michelle
president zilinski arrived behind me
just a few moments ago and before that
the vice president addressed the main
ballroom here a room full of diplomats
and security officials where she told
them national borders should not be
changed by force and although russia
says it's ready for talks its actions do
not match its words
you are convinced that president putin
is going to invade ukraine is that what
you just said a few months yes i did yes
but until the moment he does president
biden says there is still time for
diplomacy make no mistake
if russia pursues his plans
it will be responsible for a
catastrophic and needless war of choice
vice president kamala harris addressed
the annual munich security conference
this morning and said russia is
spreading disinformation lies and
propaganda if russia further invades
ukraine
[Music]
the united states together with our
allies and partners
will
impose significant
and unprecedented
economic costs
yesterday harrison secretary of state
anthony blinken crisscrossed engagements
with world leaders
countries are standing up for ukraine
and for the principles that are at stake
the u.s says it will defend every inch
of nato territory sending troops to
nervous european allies like poland
where secretary of defense lloyd austin
visited yesterday and announced the sale
of 250 american-made abrams tanks
whatever path he chooses united states
and our allies and our partners will be
ready but president biden reiterated
that america will not be sending its
forces into ukraine to fight russia
choosing instead to take aim at moscow's
messaging
and provide the ukrainian people with
military and diplomatic support we're
calling out russia's plans loudly
repeatedly not because we want a
conflict but because we're doing
everything in our power to remove any
reason russia may give to justify
invading ukraine
delegates here seem about split whether
it was a good idea for president
zelinski to leave ukraine at this time
even in private many american officials
advised him against it michelle
so why did president zielinski decide to
go to munich and missed all of the
criticism what does he hope to
accomplish in the meetings there
he hopes to bolster support i mean
obviously there is a lot of support for
ukraine here but the ukrainians are
worried about decisions being made about
them without them right if you're not in
the room you're not in the room so he
wanted to be here to make sure he knows
what's going on and can voice his
country's own point of view and all
these really high-level conversations
christina the europeans at least
publicly have been far less alarmist
about the odds of an invasion than the
u.s has been has that changed in the
past 24 hours
it has there's been a bit of a shift
with people i've been talking to up
until this point you know the us and the
europeans were seeing that that russia
had the same capability they agreed on
the capability what they disagreed about
was the intent and now more and more the
europeans are starting to come around to
what you heard from president biden
yesterday they are believing that
president putin does intend to take this
military action at some point and that
point is likely coming in the next
couple days christina we also heard
earlier that the president said there
still could be a diplomatic solution
until there's any type of military
action so twofold there what can you
tell us about any potential diplomatic
off-ramp and we know there's supposed to
be a meeting between secretary blinken
and sergey lavrov next week is that
still going to happen
that's really the unknown i mean they're
making plans like it's going to happen
but while those plans are happening it's
always a little bit of a look if russia
invades if russian take military action
president biden said himself yesterday
that will slam the door to diplomacy
shut so look this event is all about
diplomacy the president biden has said
diplomacy can happen until the very last
second but that clock is certainly
ticking down and even though there's a
flurry of action action here in munich
it's unclear if any of it is really
going to make a difference and stop
russia from doing what the u.s and
european leaders really really don't
want it to do and that's going into
ukraine
and one man making the decision there
with putin christina raffini in munich
thank you christina